by the power of castle a skull i am
hella mark harley i'm still here despite
all the haters best efforts to try to
take me down and ruin my self-esteem and
downvote me on spotify and send me
threatening messages oh
it didn't work here i am doing another
podcast and guess what i'm feeling
pretty good
do you know
casey one thing we'll get to in a sec
but i'm often accused of having mental
illness
that tracks in in the fight or the kid
seven right right you'd know more
specifically i like when people
throughout
he's obviously suffering from mental
illness can you be more specific
i know a little bit about mental illness
you know am i schizophrenic am i a
narcissist do you know what the
diagnostic criteria of narcissism is can
you name the nine traits that five out
of which you would have to apply to
someone
in order to diagnose them if you were in
fact a
psychotherapist or a psychological
professional
so we'll get into that in a second you
know we'll get into some diagnosable
dark triad personality traits and how
that might apply to individuals in my
life and yours and the kind of behavior
that you participate in
online but that's a really in-depth
discussion that
i think is quite frankly very
fascinating very relevant to the modern
age very relevant to my life but if you
believe right now that i have a mental
illness i want you to put it down below
i want you to put the five out of nine
if it's narcissism
if it's something else i want you to
make your case that i am mentally ill
mentally unstable
or
you know
have any evidence whatsoever that my
behavior
either in person or in line is
indicative of some sort of psychological
deviation from the norm
and being super smart doesn't count okay
all right
let's get on to the liver king meme of
the week because this was so fascinating
to me i actually ended up defending the
liver king online
to another person attacking me for
posting the liver king so a little bit
of background
i saw this you know i haven't watched
the full episode
of the liver king going on jake paul i
believe this
is his first
podcast interview episode uh unless
somebody can correct me but he actually
references it here like i'd never go on
a podcast or whatever now if you know
this podcast you know that we give a lot
of [ __ ] to the liver king because
he is somebody who says he's natural and
he's not right that's kind of the extent
of this joke or this
issue that i have with him and i've got
over it many times but when it comes to
his training methodology i see a lot of
things that i admire
when it comes to his
eating practices and what he promotes as
part of his business
i'm agnostic i don't know i'm i cannot
say and look at it and and think that uh
it's
ineffective or dangerous because as a
case study of one if this is somehow
deadly well he's still alive right
if it's somehow
working against your muscle gains well
it would seem to not be the case because
he's an extremely muscular man for
someone who's on steroids or not if
you've ever taken steroids or you know a
little bit more about that world
yes he is enhanced but also you simply
can't get to that level of
muscle size definition and density
without
working really really hard and having
your diet specifically
on point so there's a lot to be
impressed by and i always try my best as
a human to compartmentalize the
critiques i might have about somebody
and separate that from the things that i
can admire and it's almost like a test
for me
right it's almost something that i've
learned over the years that i
be because first you notice it in other
people where you go oh you're taking
this little issue with somebody you
don't like how they dress for example
and you use that as a
synecdoche
which is mistaking a part for the hole
or using a part of a thing for a hole
new york great movie by charlie kaufman
don't get it but you know maybe someday
after reputed viewing i will
it's a life it's a movie about a guy's
life that's like
you've seen it okay
i should have known casey um no but like
charlie coppin's awesome i love so many
of his movies this one was like
yeah that i people gave you money for
that huh yeah i believe that was also
his directorial debut right
yes it's like more impressive than
watchable you know in a lot of ways like
i do i really enjoyed the movie but it
was like
you almost see how his brain works in
the sense that it's drawn to fractals
you know of like i'm building a thing
that is going to constitute a larger
thing made up of these things and that
thing is going to you know
when i see his stuff it's like obviously
this guy's a genius by any stretch you
know anyone's
reasonable definition
but
that word is just always stuck with me
because it does often apply to real life
even though it's not a very common word
and he's also swapping out the real-life
city of schenectady new york now
in this instance
i'm referring to people who i would hear
people judge other people for
a component of their personality or a
single behavior or you don't like their
face or you don't like the way they
dress
and now they're attacking that person or
saying you're a bad person
because uh you know you're ugly or
you're a bad person because look at the
way you dress and you're a douche
whatever that means you know because
that's obvious it's subjective
interpretation
of something that you're looking at and
i remember thinking from a very young
age that bothers me that people do that
because
uh if you've ever been on the receiving
end of that you know that people can
dismiss you all the time for
one thing right and i
in particular feel like i have this
comment from people which is
oh i assumed this about you and then i
got to know you and you were more like
this or you know you surprised me in a
positive way now
i can say that knowing that people
aren't necessarily going to say you
surprised me in a negative way i thought
you're going to be smart and nice but
you're a stupid dick right you don't get
a lot of that but you get enough of the
other side to realize or maybe that
would get around to eventually or people
would stop being friends with you
at some point
so
i say all that in a roundabout way to
set up the fact that
it's very important to me as a value
to not dismiss everything that liver
king does just because he lies about
having steroids for whatever reason
starts in a system using steroids and uh
and sell stuff which i think is
unethical but
i do like him as an influencer i can't
help but but like and be drawn to him
in part because just training intensity
alone is one of those things that needs
to be modeled for young men i was
talking about this with
noel leyva's dad this morning when we
did a shot of video together we did a
glute workout with uh his daughter he
was great to talk to because we both
kind of share that you know old school
attitude of like
you know when i was alive or when i was
started lifting and all we had were
brontosaurus steaks and
mud for pre-workout and the asteroid hit
the earth and wiped out all the smaller
bodybuilders and therefore we were the
only ones left
it's it's fun to reminisce about that
kind of uh folklore but
we have some of these same principles
about you know working your ass off and
knowing what it feels like to go really
really hard which is going to be you can
tell me what your program is and what
the sets and reps are
if somebody can't measure their own
intensity and understand what it is like
to go to failure you're never probably
going to succeed so that's almost like
the key variable is your willingness to
push yourself through discomfort while
working out because you if you're if you
push yourself really hard even in one
set you can accomplish a lot but if
you're not willing to work hard you can
do a million sets and reps and
won't gain much so all that being said
the liver king works his ass off let's
watch this reel
when i got the opportunity to come on
here i was i told my wife i mean
everybody knew like liver king was never
going to go on a podcast
i was never going to do this [ __ ] i
was never going to do social media i
never do a podcast and now i have the
opportunity to tell millions of people
how they can optimize their own life so
you ask me if i've always been like this
guy number one no when you figure out
that you can live this way and you're
geometrically happier
and then you see it touch other people's
lives and you see that kid saul who ran
across the brooklyn bridge and you hear
15 year olds on instagram telling you
that you that they wish you were their
dad
i mean this like changes the whole
[ __ ] i wish you were my dad
all right
so it's kind of a wholesome clip
actually and i feel like he's sincere
what he's saying that like he
he said i said i'd never do social media
i'd ever do a podcast and here i am and
you know the reasons why or it feels
really good um you know when people tell
you i want you to be my dad and that's
something that people like young people
will tell me sometimes and it's funny
but it's also like
it is an acknowledgment of like i'm glad
you look up to me that feels good and
i've always worked with uh you know
tutored taught and coached from
basically from like
19 to you know 28 almost i work with
with
young men in some capacity and it is
fulfilling you know it is something that
feels good to have guys look up to you
and feel like you're sincerely passing
on good information to them
in the areas that you can i don't know
about everything but i do know enough
about hey you want to put on some muscle
you want to like be less awkward around
girls find somebody else because i'm
super awkward around girls but you know
i can maybe point you to that person
and uh you know in this instance i go
man i can relate to that guy and so i
posted it like
normally i'm just [ __ ] out the liver
king and we do this this segment every
liver king meme of the week because it's
funny and i love them but
um you know that was just a moment of
sincerity so i post that this is such a
long-winded explanation but i want to
give the appropriate context because i
also don't want to say have it seem like
i'm
you know just taking a big fat dump on
the person who wrote me when i when i
posted this
a woman wrote me to say like essentially
i can't believe you're spreading this
dangerous disinformation
and
i really try to avoid having this
immediate knee-jerk pushback of like f
you like you suck you i do go to her
page and i see that okay you've got you
know the plant in your bio and a unicorn
and this and that and again
i try to take in that information about
who this person is and where they're
coming from and not uh
necessarily use that to like attack them
but i go okay she's vegan you know what
i mean and i can see why
you know you're coming at it from this
perspective or you would have perhaps an
emotional response to this but i try to
engage and that sort of looks like uh
you know
when somebody makes a claim about being
dangerous first of all it's a little bit
rude to just be like you're spreading
dangerous misinformation it's like i
don't what did he even say to that like
he's
he's saying i'm going on social media so
it's like you can't like pass on a
message from a person that also has
messages that you disagree with
and i kind of but i will push back
because you got to get specific when you
get into this war of like generalities
and somebody's going like you're bad
spreading disinformation like if you're
too general you're going to go no dude
it's building this information but if
you can break it down to something more
specific and say
what exactly are you referring to what
is dangerous about what he's doing and
honestly i don't know so i don't know
what she's saying and i don't know
either way you know if this is dangerous
or not except that there are people out
there who
exclusively eat meat and carnivore diets
and also exclusively eat organ meats i
guess and i've actually read a while
back this kind of first opened my mind
to this possibility that it could be
healthy is this guy like
cured a bunch of autoimmune diseases
that's kind of something you hear a lot
like you know uh
michaela peterson is that her name uh
jordan peterson's daughter and and also
him
you know cured auto immune diseases and
diseases of inflammation although i
supposedly all diseases sort of rooted
in some form of inflammation
but
it's like it sounds crazy but well if it
works for that person and he's still
eating goat livers every night like i
guess it works because everything else
you tried on traditional medicine didn't
so
it sounds crazy and i know i've talked
to vegans before i go like oh this
person you know joe rogan is doing a
carnivore diet for this month and
they're like well he's going to die but
then they don't die and you're like well
the vegan was wrong
i'm not saying everything about veganism
is wrong but we had this conversation in
which i'm challenging her to give me
information and data or an article or
some sort of evidence
that this kills people and what she
basically came up with after repeatedly
kind of being like i'm looking for
evidence i'm looking for evidence i'm
looking for evidence and she's like kind
of repeating her little thing which is
you're dangerous you shouldn't be
spreading i unfollowed you because i
used to like you now this and you know
i'm kind of going that seems kind of
like an emotional knee-jerk reaction so
she finally gets to the point where she
goes look
e coli can be in raw meat
and i'm like okay so just to be clear
that's your point
that's your this is dangerous moment and
here's my proof is a link to show that
sometimes it was like a wikipedia like
sometimes e coli can be in raw meat
um or salmonella or whatever it is that
we get from you know fish eggs salmon um
or ground beef you know it's not cooked
all the way through
and so i looked up you know i remember
this this i like having devastating
rebuttals so
i look up
spinach e coli and i send it back to and
i go looks like veganism is just as
dangerous
[Music]
and she didn't like that she didn't
accept the terms of you know
me rebutting in the same exact fashion
that she presented it to me because she
wasn't giving me any context of here's
the percentage of people that die from
these diseases that are present in meat
at a rate that's much greater than but e
coli can exist on spinach too so if
there's some chance of it
and you're using the logic of sometimes
people get sick from meat
and i can go well sometimes people get
sick from plants
then i kind of neutralized your argument
right so
to wrap it up
that is my story about arguing with a
vegan do i think veganism is bad i don't
know
but i do know when i watch movies like
the game changers which i did and for a
while that was like the
vegan doctor jour where you go if you
watch it you're gonna convert oh my god
what my take away
there's lots of interesting components
of that documentary what my takeaway was
they showcase certain people and it's
like hey cool if you have unlimited
resources if you're an nfl player and
your wife's a professional chef veganism
sounds great
if you can rely on somebody having a
full-time job
to cook food that tastes like meat-based
food for you every day as a professional
athlete
and you never even have to think about
the preparation of said food put
whatever you want in front of my face
and i'll eat it but when i have to think
about more practical considerations
then it does start to break down and
then we do start to you know
like gender roles almost uh when you
look at sort of like
third world countries or places where
there's less less wealth and just you
know the struggle to survive every day
is greater i think people make less
ideal ideological choices about what
they eat because it is ultimately a
luxury so i guess i'm just grateful that
i live in a country
where i have the option to be vegan and
you have the option to be vegan or eat
meat or do whatever so for now my stance
is
do whatever you want
don't dm me to argue
i with some bs
now if you are here listening and
wondering why
i sound
so awesome today well it's probably
because i took some happy hippo kratom
or right before we went to record and
it's something i use before every
podcast because it feels like coffee and
puts me in a good mood and i really like
it and it's a natural substance and the
highest quality ingredients are what i
crave when i take this stuff so
naturally i'd go to happyhipporples.com
because i've tried other kratom products
i actually tried another one this
weekend because a friend brought it to
me and
first of all i drank it and it was
disgusting
and then secondly the dose of this thing
was really often it didn't make me feel
well i don't mean to like i'm obviously
not mentioning the brand but i was like
oh i take for granted that this stuff is
really good from happy hippo but
it is it's appropriately dosed
it tastes really great which again you
can't take for granted apparently
because i wanted to spit this stuff out
and uh it it helps me out as a nootropic
so
i hope that you
take the time to just look at the
website can you do that for me can you
click out of here and go to the website
and
go to happy hippo herbals.com and use
promo code thickboy3cs for 20 off
because you like whatever you see it's
like oh that stuff i want to get it's a
hundred bucks in total
how about 80.
you got it see you next time so you know
what was cool is i talked to ricardo my
man from oak and stone recently and i
probably talked about how last week
uh my client paul
had an issue with a shirt and honestly i
forget if i just talked to ricardo or
paul about this but
he accidentally ordered the wrong size
and couldn't figure out how to cancel
the order
uh so he called up and he got ricardo
the line and he was like that is so cool
that i got to talk to the owner
and that is cool but it also speaks to
what i've been telling you guys which
this is a small business
this is
owned run and operated by a small group
of passionate individuals and i think
that is reflected in the clothing
and my wardrobe is run by one
person who's very passionate
about looking cool and that's why you
see me today in these layers and just go
like wait a second did market a makeover
because all of a sudden i want to make
out with him and i'm going to tell you
right now it doesn't matter what your
gender is because that's a normal
response to have as a human being
seeing somebody layering a flannel over
a long sleeve
with long hair and living near enough to
the mountains where you don't know if
i'm going to take off the snowboard
today you don't know if i'm going to the
beach but it would all be appropriate in
the context of looking at me and seeing
somebody who's just
dressed like an absolute successful stud
now am i that i don't know but i get the
appearance of such and perhaps people
will respond to me differently
based on that perception
rest in peace kevin samuels he's an
image consultant if you were alive today
he would be telling you
to buy oak and stone clothing at
oakenstoneclothing.com and use hella
h-e-l-l-a
at checkout for 10 off and make sure to
message ricardo at oakenstone and say
hey thanks for the threads you rock
that being said let's get to the hella
personality portion of the podcast
because i think
that there's some interesting things
that i've been thinking about and
reading about
recently and i'm going to relate this
to
some experiences i've had
in the past weekend really now i'm
always getting a steady trickle
of uh harassment online right
people dm me about my looks about my
face about you know who i'm friends with
and
it's often
fun for me it's like a video game to
like respond and go you know either kind
of i have my little range of notes that
i respond with which is like
pointing out that you're an anonymous
profile with no avatar so you can kind
of dismiss those people at hand all
categorize people based on their looks
if they attack my physical appearance
and say you know
here's you
if you put a profile pic on your
instagram profile
um
now i normally don't post most of it
because i assume it's boring it's also
negative i post a lot of stories to my
story that are
like meme based they're real based
they're
light-hearted and fun because generally
i think that you should use social more
like i feel for me i want to use social
media to spread some sort of positivity
and humor and irony and be
self-deprecating so i think that's
always lost on what i would consider the
haters and if you're new to this channel
this is your first time listening or you
didn't hear the explanation to begin
with of why i named the show haters will
say
it's an ironic plan words that started
with me having fun with this phrase
playing a character that's sort of
cocky or
uh you know if if people use the phrase
haters will say or are obsessed with
their haters it implies some sort of
self-obsession or narcissism that in my
opinion i don't have but it's easy to
believe that just based on my appearance
i've come out to find out so
shortly thereafter a few months after
that i appeared on the fighter and the
kid for the first time
june of last year i want to say either
mayor june and instantaneously
i was bombarded with
i want to use synonyms for hate because
it's like
what it does that mean excessive online
criticism irrational criticism um
like animus driven comments that
seemingly don't stem from anything that
i've done as far as a moral
transgression because i appeared on a
show and tried to give workout
and workout advice and basic anabolic
advice in a sort of safe and responsible
fashion so looking at that morally i go
well to me i was trying to help people
sort of uh be safe out there and not
make the same mistakes that i did so if
that results in you
going to my youtube page and you know by
the hundreds or thousands and leaving
all sorts of negative comments telling
me i'm the worst actor of all time when
obviously i'm not
casey is just kidding oh my god
i slipped it in but it's not true like
and i've never said i'm the best actor
but
um my perception of myself in that
regard is like competence and they'd
also be doing it like on reels where
it's like oh cool that you're [ __ ]
on that reel that like got me an agent
and like you know opened certain doors
for me that you probably wouldn't
realize because it looks like just a
normal self tape but it's like yeah
somebody found that online and did big
things for me
so i've always been able to be resilient
to some degree because of that because
the haters quote unquote which again
come from the fighter in the kids
subreddit which is a subreddit that i
realized recently not a lot of people
know about because the normal function
of a
reddit subreddit
is to kind of discuss a certain topic
right that's generally
now within the world of entertainment
you can break it down and say um
okay on subreddits where you're
discussing people
and sort of uh well-known figures or
people on podcasts it's probably going
to lean towards
people who are
more likely to
criticize someone personally right
because at any any time that you have
like multiple people on camera or you're
discussing current events it opens up
the door to be like
he's wrong he's stupid i hate him he
treated him this way he said this about
that person rather than like a more
plates more dates subreddit i imagine is
this more positive because it's like
here's a guy talking about chemistry and
hair regrowth and stuff like that
so i accept the fact that some
subreddits would naturally be more toxic
now
the experience of of that i had the
experience that
unanimously every person that i've ever
showed the subreddit to or that have
reached out
and um
shown it to
is one of shock
it's it's one of i had no idea i mean
everybody kind of uses this blanket
phrase to flatten things out and even in
sometimes when you know somebody like
brendan who recently kind of talked
about it for the first time because he
wasn't wanting to address it before
the response of some people or the
justification of the people who
participate in this
group coordinated harassment that goes
beyond memes and jokes even though
they'll sort of define it as like oh he
got mad about memes and now he's crying
sort of gaslighting isn't it because
it's so much more than that and extends
out into the real world
calling his wife
to tell you know him that tell her that
the kids got in a car accident
calling comedy clubs calling sponsors
really doing things to affect his
business his well-being and his
psychological health and
you know i'm sure there was an
inflection point at some point people
would justify it who talked to me in the
subreddit by going
on about things like well he's become
arrogant or he's done this and he's some
some justification of he deserves this
my opinion is always unless that person
did something to you personally you
trying to harass them online
doesn't really make sense as a rebuttal
so
as i think about this stuff more and
more and as i you know i don't really go
on there myself because i get i feel
like i get enough of it
you know which is like
people calling me
fig sounds like fig has an a in the
middle
uh bgl which stands for big gay line
which is fine i'll tell other people
that nick dammit it's like people go oh
that's funny it's like yeah it is funny
now if it's used thousands of times by
people who are trying to antagonize you
it sort of becomes a symbol as a phrase
for
hey i'm about to start some [ __ ] with
you right so
i've also calibrated really well when
people message me
um
whether or not they're from the
subreddit because of how they act they
actually entitled so even if they're
trying to be nice to me they'll do
things like
demand answers or even subtle
differences like they go instead of
asking a big question like normal fans
will sort of go hey mark i had a
question about shoulder injuries in
blood and lay it all out because i know
i might not read it and you got a better
chance of getting a response if you
lay it all out and subreddit guys will
sort of put uh
they'll go hey mark
i have a question i'll leave it at that
it's like all right now i have to answer
to get the ant you know what do you want
and then on top of that they'll have
little like rude or backhanded things
that they say that i just i've gotten so
good at wrong i know instantly this
person is going to end up calling me bgl
or say that it's like an acting or say
my podcast sucks or say it it's going to
refuse and i'll call them out and
they'll deny it and be like no i'm not
from the subreddit and then like it ends
with like yeah that's where your bucket
is sucks you're just gonna diffuse and
you're on steroids and you have botox in
your face and you have lip flows in your
lips it's like oh but i called that you
can't do anything to me now because i
called it out so
long-winded intro and explanation to
me thinking about the kind of behavior
that we're witnessing and how a being in
a group and having anonymity
specifically because none of these
reddit users ever talk about their
identity a guy challenged me to a fight
today he was like mark this isn't a
threat but like we should set up a uh
i'm about your height and
um because somebody else suggested like
you should do mma with keyboard warriors
i'm like that's hilarious like keyboard
warriors people who are talking [ __ ] to
me
this guy was polite and from the
subreddit and he's like to prove your
point we can do like a kickboxing match
because i trained kickboxing in jiu
jitsu
but he's doing it from an anonymous
profile without his name
um no picture two followers and it's
like
first of all you're not the person that
i'm talking about you're not harassing
me and like maybe you do do martial arts
i hope so because it's
apparent in how you deal with people you
came at me with respect and said hey
mark like
this is not a threat it's like a
friendly offer cool i never said i'm
into like i just want to have a
kickboxing match with some random person
right and it also correlates with like
guys will go well you should fight like
we'll get to this thing and it's like
i'll beat your ass and i'll be dressed
and to go fly out to lexington to
kentucky you know fly out to naples
florida like fly out to [ __ ] georgia and
fight me it's like
i never expressed interest in doing that
if you're really that set on causing
harm to me i assume you'd put more
thought and energy into it than come out
to my city in the middle of nowhere and
attack me
no what that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever and you're delusional if you
think that's gonna happen
so
the overarching pattern of the stuff by
the way because like
the unique thing that put me on to this
you know idea and this labeling of the
fighter and the kid subreddit
as psychopathic behavior
it was actually a video by jesse on fire
and maybe we can insert it here
you have to see everything that happens
on the outside with the backdrop of this
insane harassment campaign going on
behind it because it's like it quickly
goes from brendan being this huge
successful whatever
taking out a small youtube channel to
brendan being the victim of an
incredibly large coordinated harassment
campaign that goes way beyond like you
know the stuff i was talking about
earlier about being fashionable to hate
on shop this is this goes [ __ ] way
beyond that this is [ __ ] that no one
should think is okay no one like no one
who's even moderately sane should be
down with that [ __ ] and if you're in
that group you should [ __ ] get out
you know what he's saying is
like this is above and beyond
and it's psycho [ __ ] and it's crazy and
if you have any sort of conscious you
should stop
i started looking up like do people
behave like psychos online or whatever
what's this like relationship between
anonymity and psychopathic behavior
because i'm not saying
these people are actual psychopaths but
they get online and they behave like
this here was a little thing i found
interesting from an article
um
about the correlation between
uh harassing or hating
literally just like hating comments
online and psychopathic traits despite
growing prevalence of derogatory online
behavior still little is known about
psychological factors underlying this
negative phenomenon
in the present study we aim to compare
characteristics of persons who post
hating and non-hating comments about
polish sports players during winter
olympic games in
pyongyang
it says pyeongchang here i don't know if
it's pyongyang uh pyeongchang why would
it be in pyongyang god i'm stupid um
so it must be right is that corrupt
i wish i knew more stuff about the world
it was the winter olympics in 2018. you
do your research so i don't have to 94
internet users 41 whitman participated
in the study among which 46 posted
hating comments after one month
participants were invited to take part
in a psychological survey and fill the
dark triad questionnaire do we know what
the dark triad is it's
narcissism
sociopathy
psychopathy and machiavellianism now
i believe cluster b personality traits
is something different and includes
borderline personalities b for bad they
say um we've talked about borderline i
don't know if we got an in-depth you
know deep dive into narcissism per se
but that would be interesting because so
many people call me a narcissist online
and i believe that's
sort of uh indicative of a lack of
understanding of what it means to be a
narcissist a narcissist and specifically
the the weight that you must give to
people being exploitative versus merely
your vein
it's like a you know a 15 year old's
understanding of narcissism
after one month
participants were invited to take after
one month
dark try there i was okay and filled the
dark triad questionnaire the
satisfaction with life scale the scale
of frustration and the scale of envy
results showed that high scores in
psychopathy subscale
were significant predictors of posting
hating comments online high scores on
the envy scale were marginally
significant
so
significant predictors
were uh you know high scores in
psychopathy
uh were indicative and predictive of uh
hater comments and envy also played a
part so it kind of it's a secondary um
predictor our findings provide initial
evidence that persons who engage in
derogatory online behavior
have a high level of psychopathy but
contrary to previous studies
do not have lev elevated levels of other
traits commonly associated with
disruptive behavior
our research is one of the first to
establish a psychological background of
online haters while setting a clear line
between online hating and other
derogatory online behaviors
such as
hate speech right
so
i thought that was interesting because
it sort of checks out
this is something that you could apply
to yourself if you don't feel remorse if
you attack people and
um
you know again i it's hard for me to
relate to leaving such negative comments
and also going repeatedly at people and
i'm gonna set this up
with the kinds of behaviors that are
experiencing this weekend it's not too
out of the norm but it's sort of like an
escalation of that because in my last
podcast episode i defined the word bully
i guess that triggered a lot of people
in the fighter in the kids subreddit
because i had a huge uptick in
harassment
as i also went on to defend
my friend brendan
in his uh you know
drama situation in which i believe 100
percent he's in the right and i will
continue to defend him if anybody asks
about it now
the things that i received
this past weekend included
threatening phone calls to my mother
uh where they left voicemails you know
saying [ __ ] mark harley she's a 73 year
old retired art teacher
which like
that didn't bother her if i you know but
it got me thinking because she goes who
is this who are these people calling
like because i assume in her mind she's
like are you into drugs now like is this
the cartel right my mom panics in that
way but it's not like she's not like
paranoid she's not gonna be like do i
have to watch like you're not gonna beat
up my mom let's be real you're not gonna
beat me up either but like you know
that's because you couldn't if you tried
but
you can't beat up my mom i think you
would not do that it would be to you
don't hate me that much you don't have
that but you want to scare her and you
want to scare me and you want to send a
message to me so
i understand where that's coming from
the funny part was and the remorseless
part is when you see people doing that
and i point that out because i started
posting more to my stories the exact
comments people harassing me people um
ruthlessly sort of mocking my appearance
in a way that
i believe they think they're getting to
me but you know if you were sitting
there putting your finger on my pulse
you'd see like i i you know nothing's
going on
psychologically that would be outside of
a normal stimulated state i write really
fast and people you wrote so much you
must be angry my rebuttal would be like
yes every 10 page essay i wrote in
college i was angry
you know pissed i had to get to write
this phd doctorate
you know every one of your favorite
novelists was fueled by anger that's the
only way you can write more than one
sentence so it's this stupid teenage
logic of like if you take a few
sentences to describe why the person
who's
ruthlessly mocking your appearance or
career or friends or family
if you describe that
and give it to them they go oh see
you're angry and that's bad and i won
uh
i don't think that is what you think it
is
so that was one thing and the double
down happened because i point that out i
put it online and then what started to
happen because on one story i
accidentally put grandma i'm writing
things quickly my 73 year old grandma
she also is 72 but she's turning 73
next week um
or may yeah i'm not gonna get her exact
birthday don't want any fuel for that uh
you know you hacking into her [ __ ]
because she has gotten hacked before and
uh she has been scammed she's an old
lady who was scammed for thousands of
dollars in one of those like amazon card
things and i you know that like so
knowing that
and how i felt in that situation the
anger that i felt
the rage that i felt knowing somebody
like
coerced my mom into giving them her
retirement money like
that would make me actually want to seek
out and kill somebody
you telling me that i have lip fillers
and
my face looks weird or it's like the
uncanny valley or something like that or
you know that i'm not a good enough
actor for an anonymous person online
who's never done the job before
that turns out kind of you know doesn't
really affect my mental state besides a
desire to clap back and making that into
a fun game
when i posted it online people started
saying
he's lying about it oh my god is it your
grandma's your mom obviously he's making
this up that can't be real how do you
know it's from the subreddit right
denial of actually doing it without any
evidence right aside from me going
grandma mom yes i messed up one time
and that was enough um
to spark a conspiracy theory that i was
making that up as if i'm the type of
person who would be capable of doing
that
and anytime somebody makes a wild
accusation like that i always go it's
not that's not evidence that
i think like that or would do that
that's evidence that you think like that
and would do that
the next thing was they somebody somehow
figured out well i guess it's on my
page that my
dad died in 2009 while doing an open
water swim in a series of open water
swims because he grew up as i probably
mentioned on this podcast before he uh
and well i mentioned it last week
actually the details
big old brain fart because i realized i
did talk about how he died but it's also
like if you you can google it i think in
his obituary it says he died during an
open water swim doing what he loved i
think that's really cool it's
unfortunate that he had a heart attack
but like the last few years of his life
were very happy because he'd gotten
obese and gotten overweight and had a
lot of health issues related to that
high cholesterol blood pressure and
you know diabetes
and
he just seemed a lot happier
exercising and getting really into again
you'd have to lift weights you have to
do anything even run or whatever his
thing was swimming
and i always remember him coming back
from these swims
just in an incredible mood
um
bragging about how many laps he's like
oh yeah i did you know ten thousand
yards today like and you could tell he's
really proud and really happy and really
in a good mood versus i can remember the
times when he was under tremendous
stress
um and not working out and how different
those moods are and so that's part of my
message to people like you know who are
in crisis or need to turn their life
around yes you might end up having a
heart attack that never would have gone
away because the plaque in your arteries
you know was there from the damage that
you did
while you were having that extended
period of overeating and not exercising
but the quality of life that you can
give yourself
you know by turning that around is
tremendous and i've seen it and i have a
lot of empathy for people who are
overweight
um so
people started using that people started
going that's why your dad drowned
himself
because
he hated you so much or whatever and
again it's another thing where it's like
it doesn't even register a blip on my
radar emotionally
but
now i know
there's a line in the sand where you can
go hey other members this is a member of
yours he's speaking in the subreddit
language he's speaking
um you know on behalf of your group
not an outlier right maybe slightly more
extreme or maybe you disagree with this
but he's one of hundreds
just over the course of a few days
leaving thousands of comments
on me on in dms on the t5k on the you
know all over the place i can say
collectively thousands of comments you
know
and that kind of becomes the shorthand
for
like
we are trying to cause you psychological
harm we're attempting to do that luckily
i'm in a position where i'm more
psychologically resilient than that but
you know
people have killed themselves over much
less right and
that's just the truth i'm lucky that
i've this the
ship has sailed from
the point in my life when something like
that would have bothered me and also you
know it's funny
because here's a narrative casey that
people always say um
[Music]
they'll be like
you take steroids because you're so
self-hating or like
he was a skinny theater door because
they've seen like videos of me when i
tried to get down to like 200 pounds by
you know running every day for example
and so it was interesting seeing people
like wildly misinterpret this thing like
oh no i was there like
i was 250 at the age of 18. and then i
was running away from that because i was
insecure about being perceived as an
unintelligent meathead right and i
wanted a physique that didn't draw any
attention to itself and i experimented
with that and ultimately found i really
like lifting weights
you know started with trt when i was
like 34
and the physique that you see now is
actually representative of my current
comfort level with how i've always seen
myself so the current me
from my perspective
is going you are meathead who gives a
[ __ ] if people project onto you you've
arrived at this place where
i like being the size that i am maybe
i'd like to even be a little bit smaller
there's no endless search to get bigger
i usually look in the mirror and go like
i could probably lose a few pounds of
muscle because i'd fit in clothes better
and look less bulky on camera those are
the type of thoughts that i have
i don't have like an eating disorder or
body dysmorphia i pretty much see myself
almost exactly like i am and pictures
and how other people perceive me um and
i know what it's like to have elements
of body dysmorphic because when i was
first 18 and trying to
you know take steroids to get bigger
there was this element of looking in the
mirror and going [ __ ] i'm 250 but i'm
skinny and i don't like the way i look
oh my god my arm looks small i remember
having those thoughts i don't have those
thoughts anymore i feel very grateful
for that and i empathize with anybody
who really
looks in the mirror and doesn't see
something that represents reality
because you can't speak logic or
reason into those people's minds right
so
i just wanted to address that because i
think it's funny but it's like
if you're attacking me and i say that
it's like it sounds like it's going like
no i'm not not insecure
but like yeah at one point i was and i'm
insecure now about other things but
like
my body like you know
i went off steroids during the pandemic
i was totally fine with my body as long
as i'm lean i'm actually like oh i
arguably i look way better you know just
looking like 215 or 20 pounds you know
you can do a lot more things but i've
made this decision i know what i look
like
and um it's hard to attack me from that
perspective
even though you're convinced you're you
know yourself that you're looking at
somebody whose body is a representation
of self-hatred or that i hate my face
and i've done anything i've never had
surgery on my face i've never put an
injection in my face i've ever put
anything on my lips
but that's your narrative and again
aside from the jokes that i always say
about like if you're looking at me and
you think my lips have fillers in them
maybe you want to kiss me
because you're gay and that's probably
true your lips have fillers in them
yeah now i'm going to go to gay bars now
guys you make your laptop fellows can we
make out
um
but
it's just one of those where i just like
i throw up my hands and other people see
it's funny so it's like i don't feel the
need to defend myself that much but like
i have botox can we see all the wrinkles
in my face what part of my face has
botox i have a gaunt face like there's
nothing in my cheekbones where's you
know like i have a little fat here why
would i put botox here you know
so um and i do like you know like all
that can you know i like i if i was
gonna go botox i'd get it like right
here i'd would do it maybe someday if it
starts to bother me right now like my
wrinkles don't really bother me
my pectoral asymmetry bothers me so um
open up with my dad people start mocking
me
and i go like oh thank you duke thank
you for like showing me what the fighter
and the kids subreddit the level of
toxicity because again people everyone
gets hate online i'm like no no you're
talking about like we all have tall
buildings it's like this is a
three-story building
that's the empire state building right
the two aren't the same
uh you know there's levels to this [ __ ]
and i've never personally seen anything
as psychopathic as the tfat k subreddit
because again
the key here is the remorse element when
you're thinking about psychopaths one of
the big defining factors is
there's no remorse there's no anxiety
there's
no conscience
and the behavior that i see lacks a
conscience it's really like a one in the
thousand outlier that a reddit guy will
admit to having said mean things to me
and turn around it happens it has
happened a handful of times and i know
for every person
that expresses that to me there's
probably more that don't but it's like
absolutely dwarfed by people who seem to
exhibit no remorse about harassing
bullying
me who's only tertiary related to the
thing that you'll go on and on and on
about what a big problem you have with
this person and why he's so terrible and
racist and arrogant and beats kids and
you know it's like
first of all that's not true but like
you don't even seem to care about those
things you know like you're
this big advocate for whatever you know
you like
you're a pedophile and that's my big
thing it's like oh yeah you so you must
be really mad at the catholic church or
you must do something outside of this
online bullying activity to you know to
also combat this thing that you seem to
care so much about that you're
justifying your own behavior and of
course the coup de grace of that
irony was when i made a video about
bullying and the response to that
was more bullying
i made a video defining
bullying in a very reasonable way and
said
you simply can't define this as bullying
because it's somebody
who apologized for attacking somebody
who it turned out didn't have uh you
know
any knowledge of the thing that the
person was talking about i made this
analogy of like
you know i think you ate my lunch
because i saw you walking around with it
and disappeared but you go oh no no i i
was walking around with it but i put it
in the microwave i didn't eat it
and two seconds ago you're like [ __ ] you
you took my lunch i can't believe you
thought you're my friend and then you go
oh no no it's a microwave you go oh my
god dude i
i'm so sorry
is that bullying or is that anger in
response to something that distinction
is very important i made it and in
response to that
i get bullied
to show me how wrong i am about bullying
kill me right now because that is the
most ironic thing i could ever
experience and that's what i live for
lay me to rest
it doesn't get more ironic than that
and then if it escalates to you
discovering in that same episode
that i
you know
was thinking about my dead dad
and how he died specifically in water
and then you make
a comment about that to mock me and say
it was my fault because he hated me
um when we had i was talking about my
close relationship with him
and then i block you and you make a
profile
that features a picture of my dad and
splashing water
and a reference to his death
again like
it's just the response that i get is
like oh like
they can't stop you don't have any
remorse
you don't have a conscience and you're
acting like a psychopath online and you
should snap the [ __ ] out of it because
you're obviously not doing anything
productive with your life
and you're going to extreme extreme
degrees
to try to make me feel bad it isn't
working but guess what i get to do
expose you publicly for the kinds of
things that you do
and the kinds of things that the other
people in your 70 000 person group
don't seem to have a problem with
right
the rebuttal to that that people will
make is
um
oh well your friends have done bad
things
if you look at that and say that's too
extreme but you're still engaging in a
small portion of it you know it's like
saying like
like
you know
like yeah those guys are stabbing way
too much like i just stab people once
and then i walk away but like this like
this okay that's like an outlier he
stabbed 10 times it's like okay it's 10
times worse whatever
you're still advocating stabbing i don't
advocate stabbing or the thing you know
that you're trying to do you're bad
because you but i don't engage in that
so your ethical problem is with somebody
else doing something that i don't do if
you feel i do the same thing and
contribute to a
a thing that needs a group aka online
bullying you're part of the problem
so
the response i think will be interesting
for all the people who will inevitably
watch this are you going to continue to
contone this kind of behavior
or not can you look at that and say hey
that's wrong and perhaps i've been
indoctrinated into a group
that left unchecked has
tainted my way of thinking and i
encourage you all to watch a video by
jesse on fire the entire thing that
breaks down and turns on its head the
narrative that brendan schaub deserves
the hate that he gets in the mma
community and in fact you should be
ashamed of yourselves
just for the sake of
the
tiny tiny tiny number of guys who even
leave mma to find happiness in pursuit
of anything after they enter a career
in which you sacrifice your body and
your brain and your youth
for a fleeting chance at glory and most
of them don't make money and most of
them never become champion the vast
majority never become champion of any
organization let alone the biggest
organization in the world and you're
gonna laugh at somebody for going six
and five i had one winning record when i
was in college playing football at the
d3 level do you know how proud i am of
going six and five
at pomona college
in the southern california
interscholastic athletic conference it
is my crowning moment
of my entire football career getting a
sack against trinity college or trinity
university whatever it is
they had gotten second place in the
nation last year they beat us 66 to
nothing the year before and came in and
we beat him and i got a sack like
i'm so proud of that and nothing anybody
says can take that away from me and if
you try to by dismissing me
like and what if i was like six and five
in the best conference in the world like
i'd be like are you insane
like we're talking about going up
against alabama and georgia and the sec
and you're mocking me for going six and
five
after only starting to play football
when i was 16 or whatever the analogy is
to somebody starting fighting when
they're in their 20s so
jesse on fire
his video about brendan i just
he gets it he nails it and i think it's
time for this narrative to start
changing on him because
that's the origin of it you're here
hating on me be honest with yourself you
never would have found me had it not
been for him
and had you not found a way to
psychologically justify your insane
treatment in a group anonymously with
this person uh you never would have
ended up here
making fake profiles
mocking the death of my father in a fake
profile dedicated to my dead diet and
how he died oh my god how what time are
we at
50.
so let's finish it off with some this is
why we can't have nice chips
thanks for listening guys i'll be back
next week i'd like to say it's the only
time i'm ever going to address it but
guess what
now this is on behalf of my dead dad
okay
and i'm gonna keep swimming
all right so this guy says
the caption there is
what
get big they said
there's something at the beginning that
like i just thought this was funny
because i relate to it get big it'll be
fun they say
so we can't fit in the shower
now is the opening the whole thing i
don't know but yes this is the reality
that a lot of people won't tell you
about now he's got great genetics he
probably was stocky to begin with but
like i was talking about earlier
does having huge muscles make you look
cool in clothes well if they're oak and
stone clothes sure but
uh outside of that you know if you can
layer them
on top of each other and kind of look
like you know maybe i've got snowboard
pants on and i'm gonna go for
a sash later
you know like like who knows like long
hair layered clothes snowboard pants
like i'm about to rip the park dude
um
keep that in mind before you gain 50
pounds of muscle
there might be some downsides to it you
might not be able to fit into suits off
the rack oh no
what's the next one there
this is uh a little something something
that i'm gonna call the butt row okay so
he puts that handle that you normally
put under the barbell
uh if you're if you've done a lot of
back work at a gym you know what i'm
talking about
but this guy's ass cheeks
are so tense and so strong that he's
able to row this guy up and down
just from the strength the tension
strength from this guy's butt cheeks
clamping together
is there a name for that like clamping
strength you know it's like
uh
there's different kinds of like strength
or force or grip strength i guess yes
it's your ass cheeks grip strength
that's what we're looking at and this
guy has it in spades i want to know your
glute routine buddy
so this girl is coming up she's trying
to get a leg workout and i know you
ladies relate to this this guy sees her
struggle for two seconds and he's titty
spotting her
it's too much it's wrong guys don't ever
spot by the titties you gotta do it on
the ass cheeks all right next one
i'm calling this curling tutorial gone
wrong the per person said don't don't
swing it go up and you know what you're
gonna wanna do is
he can't handle it he goes up takes the
weight out of the guy's hands it
immediately drops to the floor almost
like a lead weight
because he's trying to curl a lead
weight
i seem staged but also they did a great
job of making me think it's not because
of this like
closed you know circuit uh camera
footage all right let's go to the next
one
we're at an outdoor olympic
weightlifting event this guy's about to
snatch a pretty decent amount of weight
he explodes gets it overhead oh it's off
balance oh no he has to run forward to
catch it he throws it on a spectator
like
that could have been avoided in so many
ways if you're at that point you got to
duck under it right so this is why we
can't have
outdoor
snatching events because um at the end
too casey it looks like he's destroying
it at him maybe this guy had a
vindictive issue with this guy he's like
oh yeah you think you're gonna bang my
wife and get away with it i've been
waiting for this moment
i especially invited you to sit in the
front row actually the guy's taking a
picture it looks like so
like everyone's self where he's like oh
he doesn't react to the very last moment
because why would you expect somebody to
throw 300 pounds at your head
at a lifting event what's the next one
smith machinist for betas a gym phase i
recommend skipping the guy sits down and
does incline takes his chain out at
first i thought he was going to say
lifting with your chain it's a phase i
avoid lifting videos thinking that the
smith machine is for betas couldn't
agree more had a great chest workout the
other day in which i did really high
incline presses on a smith machine where
you bring it up to your neck love rowing
with the smith machine too don't be
afraid
it's got like a stick ma
but it's actually really useful
this one could it be the worst spot ever
this person comes down he's got somebody
is that a man or woman i don't know but
he struggles and it comes it's like the
worst lift ever but it's also the worst
spot ever because they got their arms
here they're out to lunch and the
reaction time on it you know when you're
dealing with a heavy barbell near
somebody's neck you got to be on top of
it even if your hands aren't there you
got to be ready to spring into action
and that second delay is obviously what
killed this teenage person rest in peace
i title this the craziest lift ever i
love this trend of just like adding more
stuff onto
a lift that you're doing like you're on
a skateboard doing a kick flip while
dead lifting or whatever it is this
guy's going up to a barbell he's got a
safety bar on his back and chains and
all that normal stuff we've seen before
in these crazy videos except what else
he got he's got a planet like like solar
system model over his head he's got like
game cards everywhere what else is there
casey can you see
like it's just like random junk from his
garage all over the place
it looks like it's a science project on
his head and then that's all that's a
good way to put it he's like a human
lifting science project
um and i feel like this might be the
culmination of all these can you say the
game cube
did you mention that i think that's good
so i just gotta give it up to this guy
because
you
have beaten
this
trend right you like maxed out the trend
um not to be mistaken with maxing out
the trend which i've done because i am
on trend guys i hate to break it to you
but i've been on trend my entire life
and i'm never getting off and if you say
that i'm an addict [ __ ] you i don't need
an intervention all right i'm going to
be on trend till the day i die which is
probably going to be next year because
trend is dangerous don't do it kids
unless you want to look like me
you